I'm good
I couldn't prison
from the reception it was clear this is
former president Donald Trump's race to
lose facing multiple criminal
investigations with more expected far
from running from his potential
imprisonment he's running on it if I
weren't running I would have nobody
coming after me
only one of his potential Rivals even
mentioned his criminal liability and it
didn't go well Donald Trump is running
to stay out of prison and if we elect
no I know I know listen I know the truth
the truth is hard
if we elect Donald Trump we are
willingly giving Joe Biden four more
years in the White House only a few
candidates dared to even make a valid
reference to Trump the siren song of
populism unmoored to conservative values
because different times calls for
different leadership
to defeat Joe Biden I believe we must
give the American people new Republican
leadership
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis who was
Far Behind Trump in the polls but
leading everyone else hello Iowa is
trying to paint himself as willing to go
farther than Trump in office I pledge to
be the president to finally solve the
issue of the Southern border we're
sending the military to the Border yes
we will build a border wall and we will
use deadly force against the Mexican
drug cartels as these Republican Party
leaders filed out the event over it was
clear the unprecedented criminal cases
against Trump are not hurting him at all
well I think that's kind of the way
politics operate anymore they just
I really don't believe that he's a
criminal or instead of anything wrong
what he said about if he was really low
in votes and not popular and not
actually posing a threat I think those
charges will drop immediately the dinner
now concluded the official race is
underway with just about six months
until the Republican caucus in Iowa it
is clear that Trump is in the lead and
not even allegations of breaking the law
are breaking into it Patty culhane Al
Jazeera Des Moines Iowa